m
une vie vouée à l'agriculture c'est sans
nul doute cette abnégation que
récompense la plus haute distinction
dans ce domaine à rimont dont l'homme de
terre qui sera ensuite homme de dossier
en portant la cause elle fait colle au
conseil général et à la mairie du tampon
était fier de recevoir la médaille de
commandeur de l'ordre du mérite agricole
plus haute distinction des mains de la
présidente du conseil départemental en
présence du maire du tampon andré thien
ah koon et de toute la famille justice
aujourd'hui effet puisque on rend
hommage avec cette médaille qui étaient
remises arrive tu es méritants
aujourd'hui tu le fut hier de neige ne
doute pas que tu le seras encore avec ta
famille ceux qui ont repris le flambeau
je te remets l'ordre du mérite agricole
comment dès lors se vanner le long du
mérite à l'école d'agriculture de
plusieurs générations pour moi j'ai de
s'éteindre et cantonaux
recevoir cette médaille mais c'est cette
médaille je la partage avec tous
ma famille est bien entendu tous mes
collègues à vis de ce qu'il nous faille
la chance même méritants
et tente aussi de médaille je pense 20
ans conseiller général 25 ans du rohmer
plus tampon mais c'est surtout la grande
aventure à l'école d'art immonde qui
était saluée dans la salle municipale de
la mairie du tampon
l'homme à l'origine de la création de
locaux pas de la frc à de crête d'or
avoué toute sa vie et continue encore à
avoir une vision pour la les cultures
pays pour la réunion je pense que le
développement de la réunion
puis à se fuir avec les pays
d'environnement il me semble que tout
roule et l'afrique
c'est dans le futur dans les cinq ans
par avion ou même un peu plus
c'est le futur
ce qu'est l'homme
exceptionnel qu'il est leur terre
écossaise qui connaît bien
ban cité rivage et puis
c'est avec une grande émotion qu'il a
reçu sa médaille entouré de son épouse
et de ses enfants des enfants qui
reprennent le flambeau agricole et
politique puisque sa fille laurence est
une toute jeune conseillère
départementale
c'est sûr que c'est une fierté de voir
son père avoir le plus haut grade du
mérite agricole
mais je pense que s'ils reconnaissant de
tout le travail qu'il a fait pendant de
nombreuses années au service m'a des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui c'est la
récompense de tout le travail qui a fait
un retour pour la profession agricole
bourget ont drainé jozami je voudrais
plus nassima monsieur le sous-préfet si
vous devez recommencer je re commence b
la même chose une vie de labeur mais
surtout une vie au service des autres
c'est autour d'un pot de l'amitié que
s'est terminée cette cérémonie émouvante
et harry monde on promet de lever le
pied à retraites est prévue pour la fin
de l'année
mais difficile de l'imaginer ne plus se
préoccuper de la chose publique ses
petits-enfants parvenons peut-être à le
faire changer d'avis